hey everybody Doug Walker here uh no Rob
this time he did see it and he usually
post on his Facebook what do you thinks
about it this is just one of those weeks
where time is really tight obviously got
the bum review and then establish a
critic that Disney's embers are starting
up pop quiz hotshot is gonna be running
through December as well so it's one of
those times where time is money so yeah
this is just my really fast review of it
buddy a few why nobody thinks go to his
Facebook he always writes up something
so this is just my brief thoughts on
okay so this is the last of the Hunger
Games Movies this is Mockingjay part 2
and I in my opinion these uh these
movies just get better and better I
think they sort of start off as this you
know like everyone said that this ripoff
of stuff that already kind of existed
but it kind of comes into it so it can
creates its own sort of idea in its own
philosophy and theories and stuff and I
think it turns out really really good um
this is once again continuing the story
from the last one of Katniss and this
giant army rebellion trying to take down
snow and it's going through the city
trying to get to the end which is filled
with booby traps so once again it's kind
of Hunger Games
esque you know because they're like
going through this obstacle course again
but it's what is so great about these
movies as they keep going on especially
is that they keep taking these ideas
that you have seen a million times and
you think you're gonna be tired of but
they give it a new spin and they put in
so many good people behind it uh the
direction is really really good there's
it's slow pace but in the best way in
that when something happens you feel the
energy from it and what they say carries
a lot of weight everything feels earned
when we get to these really tough
moments and really the big thing for me
is the acting in these movies are so
good you know in the first one you kind
of had more the you know the upper class
with the goofy costumes and they were
all going over the top and stuff which
kind of makes sense because it's the
media and if our media has taught us
anything is that we're just giving more
and more over-the-top and I should know
so it's something where when you get to
the grittiness though of these tough
people going in
it doesn't feel fake it doesn't feel
like the dialogue being said has been
written by a writer and these young
people are trying to act really tough
cuz I don't know I feel like I've been
seeing that a lot of movies sort of like
this fake tough where in the old days
when I say old days I mean kind of like
80s and stuff yeah but even then I mean
people like you know like Russell Crowe
or um
Kevin Costner those campy I always pick
on those two those are just the two come
into my mind where they do this I'm
tough I'm just gonna act like I have no
emotion and that's tough but everybody
here they're not too emotional but
they're not applying slate either they
find that perfect balance and everybody
is believable you you just trust that
everybody what they're saying they're
really saying it because that's what's
going on the moment that is what they
would say but they're also smart and
they're intelligent and it just feels
very very legit uh so this is not gonna
be I'm not gonna have any spoilers in
this at all if you want the spoiler
version go to bum reviews uh but I do
have to talk about the last third of
this without giving anything away but
it's important to bring up because all
the advertising and even kind of the
movies in general as they keep going on
they're building up to this giant big
battle this return of the King style
battle where the heroes are gonna go in
and the bad guys are gonna put up a good
fight but they're gonna knock them down
and they're gonna say the cool
one-liners and you know the revenge and
the victory is all gonna be there that
is not how this movie ends um I'm not
gonna give it away but it's it's an
ending where as it was going I didn't
know how I was feeling about it I'm like
let me let me just see how it plays out
and when it was all done it felt very
right it felt like this was the right
direction this story should have gone
because it is building up to one thing
and then you kind of realize it's about
something else
and
they do it in such a clever way where
you don't even realize it's happening
and I think for a character or even
characters that are constantly being had
are constantly being tricked uh you
still kind of buy it I was at one point
I was saying oh my god really is Katniss
you know which he you know duped again
and stuff but there's this legit
you're with her because you see
everything going on around her and it's
one of the things where when it happens
not only does it happen but you see her
kind of account for it and you see her
try to make up for it um and you again
without her saying too much you see kind
of the wheels turning and her putting
everything together and I it's a perfect
mix of how much do you say and how much
do you not say in my opinion and it goes
in a direction that islands see coming
I'm gonna take a wild guess and say it's
in the books because I can't see a movie
studio saying yes this this is how the
ship end so it's one of those things
where it's I like the direction it goes
even if some of it doesn't make that
much sense if you kind of want to know
you can go watch the bum review but
there are some things about that don't
quite add up
and another thing doesn't quite add up
again I talked about the bum review is
as you can see in the trailers and
everything Peeta is brought back and he
slowly sir trying to get his sanity back
for it stuff as they make this world and
they make kind of these rules this very
kind of emotionally logical sort of
setup that they have where even Katniss
knows okay with him here I'm gonna be
compromised I need to stay away from him
and stuff like that there's a lot of
times where they show treat this guy
differently they they probably should
have killed him just the way they talk
and the way you see all these people go
and stuff like that it's like dude this
this guy would be gone in a second like
they would get rid of him I don't want
to see him die or anything but it's just
in this world they create where this
stuff happens he'd be gone he'd be
totally gone so that's one of my issues
with it but it's minor I think though
the
the other part were the only thing that
threw me off a little bit again is that
you think this ending is coming it's all
building up to and when it's not
you're kind of thrown off and you're
almost like so we're still going with
this are we gonna have another big
climax or we have another big fight like
what's gonna happen you don't quite know
it feels a little longer than needs to
be at that moment but when it all plays
out I thought it felt right I thought I
felt like this is how this story should
end because everything in this in the
story I think probably from to on I in
you could even argue the first one but
really from to on now even the first one
it's all about the manipulation it's
about the manipulation you know of the
game of media of politics of war and
it's all about what's really going on
which that's why the reasons I love
these movies so much is that you can
watch it and especially cut again I
brought this up in the bum review
there's this thing where it's like with
everything going on politically right
now and with France and everything
there's talk about refugees and what
they do with the refugees and stuff like
that and it's very obviously this is not
commenting on anything that's happened
recently I mean very clearly and I don't
know if anyone would watch it and think
like ooh ooh that's really so that's
what they're saying we should do with
you know refugee I that's not at all
what they're saying it's very clear but
I think even before I got to that moment
I was realizing that all this stuff
about rebellion and fighting back and
the true enemy and stuff like that if
there's anything these movies have
taught us in my opinion I think it's so
good
to get to younger people this message is
you don't know and you I can almost be
100% certain you will never know that's
the one thing that I know is that I
don't know they're everything from media
to politics and all of it there's a
million things going on there's billions
and billions of people in the world
every single one of them has their own
motivation and their own cause and
there's millions of causes and we're
just never
know exactly what's going on what the
answer is what the best thing to do is
what good is what evil and any of this
stuff so many people you think are good
can be awful so maybe if you thought
awful can do good things and by first of
all these things and I think this is a
very clear sign that you just gotta do
the best you can and you're never gonna
have all the answers and all these
people that tell you I have the answers
I know they don't they are guessing and
they might be closer to the real answer
than the rest of us that are guessing me
I don't know like I'm not a political
person I never pretend to be or any of
that stuff or even with films I don't
know what's going on behind the scenes
or with directors or producers and any
of that stuff so I try never to make
them personal attacked with all these
people there's millions of things going
on and I think this very much shows that
there are so many things going on you
can never nobody can fully understand
nobody can fully see it and so you do
your best and you just have to kind of
go along with it and make the best
decisions that you can and you're gonna
make mistakes
but you're gonna make right choices too
and you just gotta go with your gut and
it's not always gonna be right but it's
the best you can do and anyone that says
they know it all that they they have the
answers they don't they do not know and
don't believe it if they say they know
you know you can say that they can say I
have a very probable outcome that this
could happen you know but that doesn't
sell posters that doesn't win campaigns
so they use this manipulation and we
fall for it because we want to believe
that they have all the answers because
we don't have the answers but they don't
either so it's that's what I got out of
this film series I think is so important
as well I think it does so well it earns
this toughness it earns this really dark
I mean that even more people died in
this I mean we see younger people die
like little kids yeah I know hey Hunger
Games kids died but like little little
kids in this die and it feels earned
though it feels like this is all about
the manipulation and every time you
think you have a grasp on or you know
what's right and wrong there's always
something else that
gonna challenge you and how much of your
humanity do you hold on to and your
ethics and how much of that manipulation
do you adapt to cuz you need to adapt
you know
this I'm not in front of you right now I
recorded this earlier that this is all
manipulation but you're using it to get
across a greater point uh but how far
can that go for things are good and
things are bad there's no clear answer
that's what I got out of these films and
especially this last one seeing how it
all ends and how it all ties together so
I really think it's good I think this is
a film series that got better and better
and threw me for a shock at the end uh
you know every single one of these have
come out I got more and more invested
you know I saw the first one let go of
it that was good it was a good movie
second one
wow that was surprisingly much better I
felt gonna be is actually really good
third one Wow like this is getting
really intense and really
thought-provoking this fourth one I mean
with this ending that they have I think
it's just it's pretty much the best way
you can end it and I think a lot of
people are gonna disagree I think a lot
of people are gonna want to see that
traditional big battle like I kind of
did going in but I really have mad
respect for the way that they went I
think it was a very you know kind of
brave choice in that you don't give them
what all the propaganda in these movies
the propaganda she's been filming and
trying to tell everybody we're building
up and I love that I love that they can
show your main character who is this
very triumphant hero and very complex
and very interesting but also very
simple you know can also be led the
wrong way if even on the side that she's
that she knows the best side to be on so
I really like I think this is a good
segue for younger people to think you
know maybe maybe the world isn't out to
get me but maybe I shouldn't trust
everything either it really is not so
black and white and there's always gonna
be compromises and it's not even as
basic as good versus evil there's just
the best situation - the worst situation
um so I really liked it I came out of it
saying this kind of stuff and I
that's a good that's a good ending to a
film series that's just a good film
series in general so I really liked it
um I thought it was very very cleverly
done and the film series like I said has
really I can see why so many people got
behind these books because when this
movie was coming out like nobody thought
was gonna be anything but all these
people that read the books right no this
is gonna be a big hit
trust me like this is gonna be a really
really big thing it has this huge
following and I can see why it's a
especially for young adults I think this
is a challenging interesting
thought-provoking series you know
disguised as just a hey defeat the bad
guys you know action arrows and stuff
like that there's actually a lot more
thought that goes into it that in my
opinion really prepares them for
adulthood and the kind of ethics that
you should have going into adulthood so
I greatly enjoyed it as an adult I
greatly enjoyed it so that's about it
and I will talk to you guys later
take care